we have folks here on the property who
are occupying the trees 24/7 and we're
just basically going to get in their way
because at this point there's not really
any other options to make them stop
[Music]
Donkin February Elyse Gerhardt and her
family decided to live in the trees to
stop Sunoco logistics from seizing part
of their property we've fought with any
means possible try to go all the routes
that we could legal processes litigation
petitions phone calls public meetings
community organizing and here we are the
tree State garnered national headlines
and led to Sunoco getting an injunction
against the Gerhardt's a local judge has
ordered the protesters to leave or face
arrest we really dug in here and people
see that and people want to support that
and that people believe in us so I don't
think we're going to be going anywhere
anytime soon police and her family have
lived on this 27 acre property in
Huntington County for 35 years back in
Sunoco offered the Gerhardt's 14 grand
for three acres of their property to
build the mariner east to pipeline the
family rejected it so Sunoco is using
eminent domain to seize it basically
they're saying that this project is for
the public good and therefore they have
the right to use eminent domain but in
reality it's not for the public good it
is destroying ecosystems it's putting
communities at risk of spills leaks
pipeline explosions so how did it come
to this
Pennsylvania is the second biggest
producer of natural gas in the US it
needs type lines to move that gas to the
East Coast so it can be exported
domestically and overseas pipelines like
sand no crows 350 mile long Mariner east
to
the two and a half billion dollar
project will carry natural gas liquids
from Ohio to a refinery near
Philadelphia the Gerhardt's property
sits in the middle of it I actually
found out over the phone my mom called
me up and she said so this company
Sunoco wants to put a pipeline through
the property and my stomach just dropped
when I heard that so how has the note
we've been able to argue eminent domain
first Pennsylvania designated the
company as a public utility second
Sunoco says the Mariner east to pipeline
would transport propane which could be
used to heat homes along the route and
the courts agreed ruling the pipeline
will serve a public purpose but the
Gerhardt's say that most of those
natural gas liquids will be shipped
overseas to make plastics and will
benefit the residents of the state to
that Sunoco says it's up to the shippers
to determine how the natural gas liquids
are used they're just providing a way to
transfer them the spokesman for Sunoco
declined to comment on the Gerhardt's
case citing pending litigation they did
give a statement we have followed the
proper legal process and we have gone
out of the way to avoid confrontation we
understand there are varying opinions on
our country's underground pipeline
infrastructure we will continue to
conduct ourselves according to the law
at all times and we fully expect those
who oppose a project to do so peacefully
and in compliance with the law the
Gerhardt's have lost all appeals against
the use of eminent domain
they're now waiting to hear if the
Pennsylvania Supreme Court will hear the
case no matter the outcome
Elise says her family will continue
fighting for their property I think that
there's a lot of regular people that are
making these stands against these giant
corporations and that together we do
have real power there are camps popping
up all over the place inspired by what
happens in
in the fight against the data pipeline
[Music]